und dann müssen wir ich kann es nicht
ändern meine damen und herren schon
wieder dringend über die cdu reden
deutschlands regierungspartei numero uno
steckt in einer mittelschweren sinnkrise
denn der gerade frisch gekürte
kanzlerkandidat zu armin laschet löst
sagen wir mal in keine euphorie wellen
im engeren sinne aus und dann sind da ja
noch die umfragen die union brutal weit
hinter den grünen das riecht nach
schwarza juniorpartner der rote micro
penis dazwischen war übrigens meine
arbeiterpartei egal
sicher muss man dazu sagen umfragen sind
immer nur eine momentaufnahme aber für
die cdu ist es ein furchtbarer moment
die partei muss sich endlich klar werden
wofür sie stehen will
nach der ära merkel in seiner
verzweiflung und um den eher
wertkonservative flügel zu befrieden hat
der armin jetzt sogar friedrich merz in
sein team geholt und der bedankt sich
direkt mit einem vergifteten lob also
hätten sie das auch mit markus söder
zusätzlich gemeinsam dass sie beide
unterschätzt haben was für ein harter
hund armin laschet ist also zumindest
muss ich sagen ich habe großen respekt
davor und ich war mir in den im verlauf
dieser 48 stunden von sonntag bis
dienstag nicht ganz sicher ob er das
durchhält respekt bürger für so ein
gelerntes weichei wie den armen gar
nicht schlecht halte ich nichts
zugetraut
der kommende wirtschafts finanz verkehrs
und familienminister friedrich merz hat
gerade mal angeregt staatlichen stellen
dass ländern zu verbieten weil er das
gefühl hat dass die deutsch innen da
keinen bock drauf haben weil er weiß
welche modernen themen der cdu
stammtisch hören will
tatsache ist ein teil der cdu basis ist
unglücklich vor allem die landesverbände
im osten sie wollten erst märz dann
söder und jetzt haben sie laschet viele
träumen von einer anderen cdu und von
was für einer erkennt man vor allem an
dieser personalie
der kreisverband schmalkalden meiningen
hatte maßen als bundestags
direktkandidaten vorgeschlagen
der wahlkreis ist frei weil der
eigentliche kandidat marc kaufmann wegen
der massen affäre aus der cdu
ausgetreten war
yahoo hans-georg maßen ist endlich von
der straße ein arbeitslose weniger
heute abend wird er zumindest sehr
wahrscheinlich von der cdu südthüringen
für den bundestag nominiert
man könnte auch sagen thüringen droht
eine unkontrollierte massenzuwanderung
ja glückwunsch cdu jetzt kriegt ihr
endlich euren eigenen sarrazin maßen der
die wahl des fdp manns kemmerich mit afd
stimmen damals als zitat riesen erfolg
bezeichnet hat der in chemnitz partout
keine hetzjagd sehen wollte den
anerkannten medienexperten ich sage
einfach das ist eine linke und
linksradikale unterwanderung der
öffentlich rechtlichen medien
und das kann man an personen festmachen
die in öffentlich rechtlichen medien
sitzen unverschämtheit wir haben beim
zdf keinen einzigen linksradikal also
außer horst lichter natürlich klar und
markus lanz logisch und kerner aber
sonst
herr maßen ist natürlich nur ein symptom
ein symptom für den aktuellen zustand
der cdu nicht wenige anhänger verstehen
inzwischen was ganz anderes unter den
drei buchstaben als die parteispitze um
armin laschet auch in sachsen anhalt wo
schon im juni gewählt wird und wo
prominente cdu fraktionsmitglieder ja
schon ziemlich offen von kooperationen
mit der afg geträumt haben also eine
minderheitsregierung eine cdu
minderheitsregierung ist absolut denkbar
natürlich
die von der fdp wird von wem sie dann
toleriert wird weiß ich ja in dem moment
nicht weißt aber noch gar nicht wer ein
alles toleriert könnte ja jeder sagen
hauptsache toleranz was kann man gegen
toleranz haben
selbstverständlich möchte ich dazu sagen
gibt es da auch ganz andere meinungen in
den ostverbänden aber die tendenz geht
schon zur alten cdu zu werten wie
familie mit vater mutter kind und
mindestens einem heterosexuellen hund
langfristig droht da vielleicht sogar
eine spaltung cdu nach 16 jahren mit ihr
völlig ausgemergelt wir wollen unsere
alte partei zurück die cdu vor
flüchtlingshilfe vor humor for gender
spanien damals als politiker innen
einfach politiker innen waren also
männliche politiker in geschlossenen
räumen als cdu parteitage noch so lustig
waren wie der hier 1979 in kiel
kurz gesagt wir wollen die cdu classic
den thüringen auch als cdu classic
hardcourt
ja das wird nicht einfach für den armen
armin laschet den laden zusammenzuhalten
im kommenden wahlkampf vor allem mit
parteifreunden wie söder oder märz
dietmar wischmeyer zumindest ist hier
mal empathisch
[Musik]
menschen im abseits dietmar wischmeyer
klagt an heute armin laschet liebe
mitmenschen ist denn da draußen niemand
der armin lastet einfach mal in den arm
nimmt
armin in der cdu jahrelang verhöhnt als
merkels mädchen dabei wurde er doch
selbst von mutti nie wirklich geliebt
und jetzt gefangen in der rolle des
kanzlerkandidaten piesackt ihn der
siegreiche verlierer markus söder als
analoge rest existenz aus der alten zeit
in der süddeutschen legt er nach wirft
laschet vor die dinge auszusitzen wie
einst helmut kohl noch eine provokation
belastet so 90er wie dr alban aber ein
markus söder den lieben die kids von
heute behauptet zumindest markus söder
der fränkische obama ohne groll will der
schlechteste verlierer aller zeiten den
laschet wahlkampf unterstützen ist klar
wo wir schon vorstellen wieder in bayern
plakatiert wird der arme armin mit den
tag seiner kandidatur noch verfluchen
selbst wenn er kanzler wird ständig
gequake aus münchen
und dann holt er sich auch noch fritz im
märz ins team den super minister im
kommendem kabinett und laschet kocht
dann für alle kaffee und macht
schnittchen übrigens weiß ich auch schon
wo sein erster staatsbesuch hingeht
zarate die taverna lag es in aachen
dreimal die woche kommt armin laschet
hierher bislang jedenfalls und er hat so
seine ganz bestimmten vorlieben so fasst
der sache haben wir so am liebsten so
nimmt peter ihrig oder iris komplett mit
böhmisch dreimal die woche groß das ist
eigentlich die dosis die ein erwachsener
elefantenbullen umbringt der mann hat
halt ohne frage nehmerqualitäten und
nicht nur das was haben sie was markus
söder nicht hat
schwer zu sagen wahrscheinlich eine
ganze menge
wehrheim stamp lächeln muss was habe ich
was ich nicht habe zum beispiel
schlagfertigkeit warum tut er sich das
an der armin hat doch alles ein
reihenendhaus in aachen burtscheid
irgendein gaga orten von der örtlichen
witze wehrmacht und als angehöriger der
prioritäten gruppe 3 wird in diesem jahr
vielleicht sogar geimpft
warum begibt er sich auf diesen weg der
leiden keine ahnung bin ich jesus und in
der nächsten folge von menschen nimmt
abseits begegnen wir einem
nachdenklichen robert habeck nachdem
auch bei let's dance nicht ins finale
kam
wie verkraftet der sensible philosoph
den zweitgrößten tiefschlag seines
lebens genannt
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
hallo hast du scheiße fährt haye